I don't know I I did glossolalia last
night at the rave so I my credentials
for not making sense are in nevertheless
it struck me recently with considerable
force that it's very interesting that
when we think clearly our thoughts can
be mathematically defined through
symbolic logic that's how machines think
as well machines use symbolic logic so
you know it isn't just that we are
making up sense when you are making
sense you are running a clean code that
expresses symbolic logical the theorems
and propositions that's why we can
communicate with machines and why the
output of machines make sense to us
because symbolic logic is the universal
language understood by the oath and
machines when we don't make sense
the machines can't understand us and we
cannot mathematically formalise our
thinking because it is and what is
called nonsense which is
well accepted the fact that mathematical
logic is in there indicates that this is
not a circle going on in some unnamed
through psychological dimension there is
real truth there our minds apprehended
and we know this because that truth can
be freely transferred and transformed
between us and our machines using the
formal languages of mathematics